long names Roy and rod and two dice that
diam were Transpo
Jason Statham is not in this movie or
stathom or I don't give a [ __ ] but we're
gonna watch a trailer for the
transporter refueled I'm assuming it's a
sequel or reboot whatever either way I
like the franchise I think they're fun I
love the second one because it's just so
over-the-top ridiculously bad the third
one I thought it took itself a little
too serious is still cool but I'm
interested to see what they got let's
see if this guy has the same charm as
Jason Statham does no caller ID
listen you think they call come up with
something they come up with something
else makes you wonder if you guys knock
me up we have two children now people
would always need class not neighbor
ouch - usually just no room for that
that's the old days then we have
crutches and get revenge
ah
[ __ ] like that that I love okay looks
like everything I would want it to be
this guy seems like he has a little bit
more humor to himself then because Jason
Statham you know there's a sarcasm and
Jason Statham but he's you know for most
part very brooding very serious and this
guy seems like he's got that more classy
British type of charm I don't know if
he'll be as engaging of an actor but he
looks like he's having a fun time just
from this trailer alone it look cuz my
problem with the transporter films was
when they would take itself too
seriously like it was always at its best
when they were just honoring how
ridiculous it was this one's like hey we
just know it's supposed to be a blast
we're gonna have some fun the
transporter character I'm not too bummed
out Jason Statham is not returning
because it's a pretty simple character
it's not really much of a character he
just drives people around [ __ ] and just
getaway drives in whatever looks sexy it
looks like there's a different vibe to
it and hopefully this guy does a great
job I wonder if the fight scenes are
from the same choreographers because I
believe the previous choreographer was
Corey Yuen who did a lot of like jet Lee
films that's love Jason Statham films I
don't know if this is the same
choreographer or not but hopefully the
fight scenes are just as cool anyway
guys thanks for mentioning that trailer
was out if you're new to the channel you
know you can do you can subscribe to the
Rio rejects and you can follow us on
Instagram Facebook it's where what you
doing here they don't go David Mays hey
guys I just want to say I love your
videos favorite channel of course it's
your favorite Channel
Sally is gorgeous and keep doing what
you're doing well I have a very simple
routine with my life I wake up in the
morning go for a walk and then
afterwards usually to get an extra like
endorphin boost I will masturbate to
some really graphic pornography I'm
talking like oh man
it's some pretty crazy [ __ ] and then I
filmed these reaction review thingies or
some other video for the channel
I masturbate again so david maze i may
keep doing what you're suggesting I do
and the fact that you're saying this is
your favorite channel that's really an
honor
I've heard of plenty of times so it
really doesn't mean anything to me
anymore
I'm kidding my friend I'm kidding either
one out of like three people who
consider this your favorite channel so
thank you